. So let's continue to get caught up about
the aftermath of Donald Trump, wondering aloud
about injecting bleach and isopropyl alcohol
as a possible treatment for Corona virus.
He said it.
He he floated the idea that it was sarcasm
that failed.
So Friday, he left the press briefing without
taking a single question.
We then learned he would be reducing the number
and duration of press briefings.
But more importantly, Trump spent the entire
weekend rage tweeting attacks on media for
all of this.
And that's the move you you.
He tried claiming it was sarcasm and that
failed.
He, you know, denying that he ever said it
has obviously failed since we have cameras
in 2020 and we can record things.
So Trump spent the whole weekend with dozens
of tweets, including some that he has deleted
out of shame attacking the media.
For all of this, once again, another of Trump's
authoritarian totalitarian tendencies attack
the press constantly for everything while
never taking responsibility.
So let's take a look.
A tour through Trump's weekend rage tweeting
starting with lies about virus testing.
Trump saying many testing sites are and have
been open and available.
Just past five million tests, far more than
any other country in the world.
In fact, more than all other major countries
combined don't believe the fake news.
Now, that's just a short statement, but it's
riddled with lies.
First of all, what matters is testing per
capita.
We are forty first and testing per capita.
The total number of tests doesn't matter that
much.
But also remember that the Trump administration
promised that we would have done more than
20 million tests by the end of March.
It's the end of April and we've done only
five million.
But Trump insists it's the media that is lying
to you.
Now he's the one lying to you, then going
into bleach injection saying, quote, was just
informed that the fake news from the Thursday
White House press conference had me speaking
and asking questions of Dr. Burke's.
Wrong.
I was speaking to our laboratory expert, not
Debra, about sunlight, etc. and the Corona
virus.
The lamestream media is corrupt and sick.
Now, of course, the video is very clear.
Trump turns to her and literally says, Deborah,
have you heard of injecting heat and light?
And she says, well, there is this thing called
fever.
So again, it's another lie, but a pointless
lie.
It's neither here nor there in Trump wondering
aloud about bleach and isopropyl injections.
Then maybe Trump's key tweet of the weekend
now defending why he won't be doing press
briefings.
Of course, the real reason he's going to pare
them down is it's become an embarrassment.
He says it's because of the media tweeting,
quote, What is the purpose of having White
House news conferences when the lame stream
media asks nothing but hostile questions and
then refuses to report the truth or facts
accurately?
They get record ratings and the American people
get nothing but fake news, not worth the time
and effort.
He said something that is the source of international
shame for the United States.
That's why he's being advised to pare down
the meetings.
But he attacks the media as the reason.
And unfortunately, it probably works with
many of his followers.
Another media attack.
Remember, this is the president in the midst
of a pandemic, spending his entire weekend
tweeting stuff like this, saying, quote, I
never said the pandemics was a hoax.
Who would do such a thing?
I said that the do nothing Democrats, together
with their mainstream media partners, are
the hoax.
They have been called out and embarrassed
on this, even admitting they were wrong, but
continue to spread the lie.
Remember, it's Trump who's been called out
and embarrassed internationally for saying
what about injecting bleach?
And of course, he did refer to it as a hoax
many times.
Then, amid numerous well-sourced reports that
Trump has recently been watching five to seven
hours of news every morning before strolling
into work at noon, Trump says, quote, The
people that know me and know the history of
our country say that I am the hardest working
president in history.
I don't know about that, but I am a hard worker
and have probably gotten more done in the
first three and a half years than any president
in history.
The fake news hates it.
That one obviously a lie, but we don't really
need to debunk it.
And then this is the cherry on top, a three
tweet Gong Show where he said and subsequently
deleted because of the embarrassing misspellings.
When will all of the reporters who have received
Nobel Prizes and I'm saying not Nobel Nobel.
NLB Ali.
Nobel Prizes for their work on Russia, Russia,
Russia, only to have been proven totally wrong
and in fact it was the other side who committed
the crimes be turning back their cherished
nobles again and OBL Yes, so that they can
be given to the real reporters and journalists
who got it right.
I can give the committee a very comprehensive
list.
When will the Nobel committee demand the prize
is back?
This is one sentence, folks, especially since
they were gotten under fraud.
The reporters and lamestream media knew the
truth all along.
Lawsuits should be brought against all, including
the fake news organizations.
That's capital F, capital and capital o.
To rectify this terrible injustice for all
of the great lawyers out there.
Do they have any takers?
When will the Nobel Committee act?
That's a capital, a on act.
Better be fast.
Those were deleted, I assume, because of noble
versus noble, but also maybe because it is
the agit trash that you would expect someone
on Ambien or some other kind of medication
to be tweeting out, not the president of the
United States in the middle of a Sunday afternoon,
an entire weekend after a globaly embarrassing
debacle attacking media and press as the source
of his problems.
This is not a well, man.
We're gonna do a deep dove later in the week
about how this has become a sort of last straw
for a lot of people around the world to realize
that this man is fundamentally unwell.
But what matters here in the US is whether
our voters realize that people in Germany,
realizing Trump is sick doesn't really help
him move him in November.
If Americans who don't vote realize Trump
is sick, it also doesn't help remove him in
November.
People who are going to vote or who can be
convinced to vote, they are the ones who need
to realize it.
And I don't know that they are